hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the deepest sleep the
final part in the series that I've been
enjoying for the past hours so I've been
playing them all in order so I can get
the best experience going into each one
now I did not manage to get all the
notes in the last one and I do not know
if that is gonna bite me in the butt I
really hope it doesn't because I love
the idea that I saved Cody even though I
was stuck in a lucid dream who in their
mind I woke up in the middle of the
night I couldn't move or say anything
and there was someone in my room oh hi
cold night outside I'll miss the weather
yeah is someone there oh my god I can't
move that's a bad thing
oh it's quiet my bed I can't move he
seems to be looking at me I look at [ __ ]
you who in the ah ah come on
goddammit I did what did I click on oh
sorry about that
got a little bit distracted by something
hi okay I really hope that didn't mess
up with the recording but I think we're
still gonna be okay because all I'm
doing is a little high I didn't do that
I did not click on that oh this game is
starting off with a bang isn't it huh
okay take my suit hi you gonna do this
again huh gonna be that thing huh we
were you oh good I can see that this guy
went all out with this one it's gonna be
another situation from the gray eagle
I'm gonna be scared by something hello
people start on the left all right real
with no handle hello Burt I'm sure the
snow gets to you somehow so you followed
this stupid traveler even though you
knew what's going to happen you are at
the bottom depth now there's nothing
beneath you it is important that you
avoid the bottom feeders they sense
motion so don't make any sudden movement
near them also don't go to the dark
church the darkness will suffocate you
there find a ladder should take you back
to the surface
sincerely yourself so I'm Burt I was a
clown on a poster what does that even
mean
okay a real with no ham I I was not
ready going into this you just started
going all [ __ ] on me game and
suddenly things are happening with
reckless abandon I can't read this is
that a person what is that
I can't tell okay then moldy and musty I
got a ham are gonna smash any patties in
the face got a screwdriver
I remember that stuff it looks that
painting what is that sound the sound
dynamic just changed on in Quetta me
that was a book in there
aha the bottom features they live at the
bottom layer of the realm of dreams
feeding upon everything that ends up
there even the shadow people fear them
they are blind but can sense vibrations
in movement by staying perfectly still
you should be a little bitter that's
what I'm him cuz he was writing and not
saying perfectly still so how do I know
when I need to stay perfectly still
hi okay hi okay are you a bottom-feeder
shut up phone now is not the time yes
but that on silent who's already okay a
gentleman okay it's a statue god damn it
okay thank you you idiot
fine I don't want to break the gem
alright I got the gem it's not quite the
shiny gem from the first part okay oh
hello okay so the real goes all the way
over to here but it kind of looks like
that might be a dark church's type thing
and I was told specifically not to go in
there thought I was gonna be smart about
everything in my life I would not I
break them up Oh God jeez I did not know
that was that add that that worked okay
this game is messing with me let's go in
the dark duck yeah that's a cool angle
just go ahead oh hi okay I have two gems
does that mean I need two ah fits
perfectly in the eye hole ah that's good
he is very good excellent most excellent
let's go deeper okay what is this that's
new small hole a gym what the hell is
that okay do I need to put the jam in
the other small hole okay I got it I got
I got it
oh it's not fun okay what did I do ACK
that's in my eyes the bees not the bees
okay I get it I get it I get it I get it
I need to hurry up probably maybe I
don't know oh come on oh I see yeah
there's another one there it is yeah
there we go
ah thank you for whatever the hell that
is
okay oh do I have to do it all the way
back yes I do
I could do without the roaring in my
ears be nice okay okay all right I got
it
okay thank you can I have those back now
well okay never mind I don't see any
screws saw two trams maybe if I get out
of this dream it would be worth having
okay check it in your drinking [ __ ]
303 to Jimmy's it will pull the rope
down a bit okay so that's where it needs
to be okay this game what the hell why
man sewer what the hell happened okay
so there's how you want to play this huh
I am so still to see you chillin don't
mind me hi Burt
was it o-o he hanged okay that is good
sidereal plexus Corp sewer gate lock
system door bars real news what news
noose is part of your lock system so
someone has to be on the news to be able
to do the thing okay so if he goes off
the noose the bars will go up right I
think so uh you gots to go man you gots
to go
sorry Wow okay fine Danno
oh I see so I gotta put him okay ah okay
I think I get it okay okay so I gotta
get him up without a wall the Rope is
down how doesn't make any sense how
would I be able to get back here bones
won't move so I got to find a way to be
able to get him here but without the
wine okay okay I think I get it so maybe
if I put the stool there ah there we go
got it got it got it I got it okay all
right okay I got it
I thought I need to put the stool bot
like under the guy to be able to do that
apparently that was wrong slide under
there grab that nope okay so that stays
there so now you will still be there
apparently okay here we go guys
fun oh hi what are you okay that's this
hole in the wall no not what I wanted I
wanted to address the giant hole in the
wall but apparently he's not being very
talkative hi giant butthole okay
Oh
Muramasa okay that is a giant pothole
and to be perfectly honest I would say
reminds me of that thing from penny
Umbra donk what do I do about that okay
don't mind me I'm just gonna owe you
back off there sunny Jim I'm just gonna
reach for my ham are Wow
okay okay I get it I get it oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god ah come on okay
he's gonna be a bit more gosh yes
maybe if I sing him a lullaby maybe if I
sing him a pretty little lullaby okay
let it go all the way down and now we do
again
come on come on come on come on come on
god yes okay all right even if I could
close this there we go close the blinds
on that want to be a little
sophisticated here got a little more
elegant
that's his lovely H um or a lovely F or
Japanese symbol for F me because I don't
know what it means maybe it's a maze
pattern I'll write it down okay so I'm
under the assumption that is stupid and
I'm an idiot
upper drawers empty hundy rows empty
cabin is empty I couldn't have expected
anything better out of that outcome I'll
just be on my way
music box good rates good good good good
good good good no water no reflection
I'll be ugly enough it would break
anyway okay wait there's something in
the toilet is that how there's gonna be
smashing nope okay bye damn it what am I
supposed to do
ah there we go okay those golden key in
the sink how was I supposed to know that
okay so there we go that was simple Oh
blood on the walls that's a good sign
okay moving on hello giant thing hello
other giant thing is Cruise Line okay
it's another mystery it's another
mystery that I need to solve as soon as
possible hello mushroom a fat boilie
mushroom Kanna
okay I just exploded the mushroom did
not mean to do that but I guess I can
have some oil now which is useful I
think
okay library again can of Greek Oh
Greece yes absolutely I can get Greece
well this puzzle seems very simple fill
the can with oil got
the puzzles have been a bit more
straightforward in this game wait a
minute there's something there I see
something
mm okay moving on what else we got what
else we got what else do we get hello
that wind-up key to the music box I'm
guessing stone tablet can't reach it I
gotta find some way to get to that area
but there's still more to go
hello so much Russ it stuck could use
some oil hello okay down we go into the
hatch oh okay
I'm sorry oh I'm sorry oh I've been
devoured ah didn't know that was there
thank you okay yeah okay hello giant
butthole how are you very nothing here
you don't need to worry about nothing
I'm just gonna
go back so you're there gotta be
something else than I need to get but
what do I need that stone tablet to be
able to do the thing there is something
on that wall I can see it right in front
of me
you can't tell me I don't find whatever
I'll just move on okay what else do we
have here we have a pipe we have holes
in the walls we have nothing we have a
place for stone tablets to go which
would be nice
something's blocking it wind-up key for
the music box okay windup key for the
music box okay that's not good oh that
is not what I wanted
why did I do that why did I do that what
it lose a point
who's the benefit who's the possible
benefit now everything's gonna explode
me over there oh good oh good okay I
guess I gotta time it go now okay that
would be very painful okay
my stupid decision was to run straight
into it okay
ah no okay I can't go it alright then
that's good to know
hahaha oh it changed everything
oh good oh good what the hell don't oh
hi
did you lose your bed what the hell is
happening here hi stone tablet good hi
there
okay good
how many times have I said good and okay
getting a little sick of it don't hear
it okay
there's a damn paper again I know what
that is I already wrote it down here
expert art is --ml skills does that
sound that was in the other room before
but now it's in this room
I don't know oh that's what it was it
was that the whole time oh my god it was
the Pistons of the nightmare machine
over there okay so everything else went
to [ __ ] I'm assuming that over here it
kind of met a similar fate maybe what
did I get I got another stone tablet
what good does that do me a hatch can't
reach that okay all right then so I'm
assuming that's the way out I got to
find a ladder to get out of there
because that blew up
I already greased it up so there's got
to be something else that I could go
seems like a lid of source yeah okay
wait no why can I see that now not
before there we go
gears are spinning fast throw hammering
no throw screwdriver in it okay that one
did it
okay stuck for good forever and for good
so that means that I can do something oh
I can go through the the piston machines
with nightmares of super dis of kill EU
savvy done yes
oh that this seems safe okay okay okay I
better go I better go now go now okay go
now one more oh jeez you just stood
there like a [ __ ]
okay so where am I now the meathooks
make me think I'm going to the kitchen
and someone fun a cinnamon toast is that
for cinnamon toast Ken a suspicious
looking dried herb still old but still
crunchy alrighty then I got the stone
tablet that's good
smells bad here cuz that's the way back
or anything else I should know about
lost in the darkness like me I wonder
how did end up here haha lo my dozy
friends still here of course you still
are not much more to say about it ah I
got ya I got you that's cool
smells bad from there how about a hammer
no okay some stinky liquid stove must be
broken can I hit anything god I really
want to hit stuff with this hammer but
you're really not letting me I've want
to smash everything fine okay
can I hit him with the hammer towstee
with the hammer okay what I'm on my way
then alright okay
okay so is there anything else that I
should do besides just go back um okay
all right I get it I get it I get it not
supposed to be here I get it how are you
a script alder script Walter is the guy
that made this game he's done a damn
good job what am I supposed to rial I'm
supposed to make the pattern okay I got
it okay so this needs to go I need to
change this up so that goes on the
bottom right then the straight line goes
up top left square goes bottom left and
then where the last one goes the other
place you guys if you guys can't figure
that out you need to go back to
preschool what am I supposed to do about
you can I throw cinnamon toast toast
into you without appease the mighty but
gold God
but hold God person butthole of man but
he's a butthole oh I see there's another
way to go about this ah ah ah a pile of
plates you say so if I were to smash a
Rooney those plates can I smash it gasps
I got it giving ya bout here baby
oh yes haha another place I am NOT going
back down but I did I did it I did it I
got you good tonight put that there and
I'm good
screw you do do we screw G buhdoobie I
might be in a bit of a hurry silicium
okay that's a but that's it just a
little bit more okay okay okay okay
come on come on go can I go oh oh oh
this looks familiar
ah ah that's the other side of the place
oh hi Oh was a mirror than me oh my god
oh my god
now I remember they've got me all this
time I've been okay
alright one of them what no I'm still
playing so I guess that's not the end of
it I'm a monster one of them no I don't
believe it I so high what the hell is
that what excuse me who's looking oh my
god oh my god that was the guy with
suppose me in the first book I was a
monster oh my god oh oh oh oh my god
there he was and travelers just like me
before the moment I saw me started
running my ticket out here my chance to
finally wake up oh my god I just had to
catch him to possess a sleeping body a
body that I could wake Evan oh but did I
really want to have I really become a
monster so easily a monster I feared so
much oh it was so easy almost too easy I
took his body away leaving him in this
chaotic Wow I will wake up now in the
chaos of this place we'll follow me up
to the service
oh I did a bad thing oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh holy crap they like boom my mind is
in pieces all over the walls
holy crap that was awesome oh my god I
want to do it again I want to do it and
get the other one I want to do the other
one I want to do it oh I want to do it
come on come on yes thank you script
welder he made a great game who's
beautiful I want to do the I want to not
get him
okay I'm continuing the game I'm hoping
then it puts me someplace relatively
close to where I was otherwise I will be
forced to go through the whole game
again but I will do it because I want to
get that whole bye good as it is here
okay so I have the option now her I'm
coming to get you good girl I'm a
monster error I Aurora I just had to
catch him to possess a sleeping body a
body that I could wake up in her mouth
I'm gonna get you hello I'm gonna get
you okay I'm gonna let him go I'm gonna
let him go
I'm gonna let him go and I'm gonna see
what happens come on get out of here get
out of here what if that guy is me
whoever that guy is literally me he's
not just another travel as that is
literally me I hesitated and I let that
man go this vicious cycle cannot
continue I will remain here forever
here in the deepest sleep oh hi oh
that's me oh my god is but they're both
me Oh God oh it's so cool okay so anyway
that is the end of the deepest sleep
script welder that is an amazingly
incredible job oh I love it I love it
when a game has a great story and lots
of really cool stuff going on it's
fantastic wow it's fantastic
but either way wow that's so cool so um
thank you all so much for watching give
the developer all the support in the
world he made these awesome free
if you haven't checked the description
in the description the link to the all
the games that I've been playing over
the past hour have been down there give
him support he is amazing oh my god
script welder this was great can't wait
to see what you make Nick I know that
he's made other games too
I can't even say words right now I'm so
happy this is awesome so anyway thank
you all so much for watching my video
here of the amazing deep sleep series
click the annotations and description
for more series that I've done and thank
you all again for watching and as always
I will see you in the next video